hi there i'm ian ni-lewis
and I'm Dan Galpin and once again we are
here with another Friday games review
this is again a selection from your
choices from the moderator page is the
top 5 nominated games for us to look at
this week with us is also Alex over here
who is acting as producer and he's also
going to be helping us with the reviews
absolutely here let's scooch over that's
a good idea
so what are we drinking today that was
well yeah you know a lot of people were
asking me are you still gonna drink
because you're having it you know this
show is so much later exam and I'm like
dude lunch time this is even better but
I will say this I'm I I pulled what we
call in our team pulling a Galpin last
night I was up all night doing something
that wasn't actually all that useful is
actually making that intro video that
you just saw does that enter a video
awesome I loved it it is certainly
worthy of my name
absolutely but I'm totally pleased yeah
because Dan will do this would be like
you know god I was up 14 hours straight
last night and I made this you know
model the Great Wall of China from my
dental fillings and didn't actually that
was an amazing model yeah exactly mean
so the upshot is dental visit we're both
were both tired because I pull the
Galpin he is a Galpin exactly um but
that's we're not gonna let that stop us
it's noon and that means a lunchtime
beer but I will say this because I
pulled a gallop and I was unable to pull
a Louis Annie Lewis men stop by some
awesome liquor store for beer so I had
to pull what's in a fridge fortunately
we had a pretty good selection from my
what I consider my adopted hometown of
Redmond Washington we have Red Hook ESB
mm-hmm
great brewery but we both been there mom
not at the same time although we did eat
at the third farm right next door I they
have a wonderful
audio and you just sit out there next to
the brewery eat some brats drink some
some ESB and life is good that's what
that's what we need to bring actually as
some broth on to the show to go and that
would just make the show that much
better
that's right bra rod so so we're
drinking the ESB now III brought Pilsner
for Daniel Pham our engineer just in
case but I have something super special
for me there he go hey nice
I have something super special for
producer Alex because Alex didn't get to
go to Mobile World Congress this year so
I brought him back a taste of Barcelona
absolutely that's right Estrella damn
the damn stands for damn Istria again
seriously you guys don't serve anything
else in this town yeah pretty much
alrighty let's take a look at endo sekiz
right that's right okay well now we've
wasted a lot of time and the haters are
gonna hate on us so let's get right to
it
all right it's the first game we're
going to look at and urea we have our
exciting intro graphics here and I
forget it one more oh no really
yeah all right so the first game we're
gonna be looking at is agent shooter and
actually go to the go to the next slide
so we can take a look at agent shooters
there we are
mm-hmm so agents to shoot er lets you
know from the beginning that it's
ad-supported just in case you were
wondering whether or not it was free or
paid or not it's right there in the
title it also lets you know quite
clearly from the feature graphic that
this is done by like one dude who has
GIMP someone who's someone who's know
how to use the filters and other
Photoshop or GIMP but it certainly looks
like them to me yeah and and yeah but
that being said it's actually quite a
lot of fun to play I think it really is
you know I felt like this is just a kind
of game that Android needed it's a
shooter game it is it's it's basically
like yeah yeah it's a shooting gallery
like area 51 or so
he's going through and the multi-touch
makes it really cool because you can
actually multi-touch different targets
was completely unrealistic I figure I
just have things I think I have just
five guns in my hand actually is what I
look at it that makes sense one for each
finger one here I'm exactly a mime I'm a
shooting right in your fist has five gun
that's right exactly exact a pen so um
we have here the title screen of agent
shooter and you know there's really not
much to say about this other than my god
there's a lot of stuff on here and and
and where's the images are we waiting
for the images to load it felt like that
actually I actually said you're looking
at it for about two seconds thinking is
know this this is it okay well there you
go
but that being said you know you can get
right into the game here and and you see
I've unlocked episode 1 which shows you
how much I've actually managed to play
on this tablet but let's go so let's go
start this and then again the game
itself is really you know from from it's
not really designed for a tablet let's
just be honest here in terms of
graphical fidelity but as I said it's
actually fun to play and I usually play
with two with two fingers with actually
it's almost like you know being you know
two guns it's somewhat realistic and
other than I could never shoot this well
you actually feel like the graphics on
here totally remind me of area 51 this
is like that you know state of the art
for arcade machines in the late 90s sort
of graphic absolutely absolutely and and
you know it is actually it is actually
really fun you know it doesn't give it a
lot you can see that you got the
accelerometer going you've got the add
and at the bottom it's all pretty
unobtrusive now it's on a tablet
obviously that average that is really
really small so it's really really nice
and and you get a new high score it
asked your name all the time
fair enough now one thing that I noticed
immediately about this game is that they
do allow you to shoot multiple things at
once so you can tap multiple mirga's but
there's one problem and it's tough to
tell on the video because as you know
the man won't let us play sound from
these games but if you did hear sound
from it you would notice immediately
eclipses really badly they they've
cranked up the audio for you
two individual gunshot and that means
that playing multiple shots at the same
time is sure to clip this is tough
especially if you're just trying to
crank out an Android game quickly you're
probably using sound pool that would be
my choice for this type of game sure
yeah the problem is you've got to do one
of two things you either have to make
sure that your volumes are normalized so
that none of your sounds are going to
clip even if you play five or six over
the top of each other or you need to go
the extra mile and add some effects I
mean the the the thing that you need for
this and this is what we use in
Broadcasting's we use in musics what
programs use is something called a
compressor limiter it's a very very easy
thing to make mathematically I actually
wrote an article in game programming
gems eight I think on the compressor
limiter that I wrote for for Halo 3
we actually cranked that thing and used
it for a radio effect but what you want
to do is get it so the the high parts of
the sound just kind of roll off mmm so
that you don't ever blow your your
eardrums out or in this case below this
the speaker's because you're clipping so
hard yeah and I think I think it's uh
you know you can control attenuation in
sound pool so that's that's you know
then that's the other way to do it is
you can you know given the fact that you
have a you know a maximum of sounds
you're gonna be playing it one time it's
a little tricky because sound pool
actually doesn't give you any knowledge
that your sound is really playing and
necessarily it so you do eat it it is a
little bit tricky but I think I think
that the easier thing to do is to is to
try to lower the sound volume a little
and or you know you could go the extra
mile and actually write your own mixer
with effects processor yeah but at the
very least you know do what we used to
do when we didn't have good computers to
play games on and write yourself a fake
compressor so basically what you're
trying to do is based on how many sounds
you've played and within a certain
period of time just drop the volume down
you drop it down a certain amount for
each sound and then you let it come back
up slowly you know just right
a little you know windowed average
engine to do that so but the main thing
is you know make sure especially if
you're going to be playing a lot of
sounds you know this would have been
very easy to test and it's surprising to
me that the developer let it ship in
this day well you know again this site
this this is a this game is really cool
it's clearly one guy and clearly you
know that was not his priority was sound
effects I mean that's true but the game
is really fun and you know again there's
just a lot of UI stuff here you know
it's hard to tell how much this is
tablet-specific since i only have to
play this on this tablet you wanted
things that's interesting is there's
actually sort of a wizard that that goes
on as you're going through the levels
and it is a little bit jarring given
given the kind of composition of
different elements that we see here on
the screen at once we have like some
Android elements some bitmaps some sort
of bitmap creations of similar Android
elements and you know it does feel like
there's there's at this point it would
make sense to actually bring in a
designer and have them take a look at
all of these intro screens because the
game itself is really really fun and you
don't want someone to go through at the
first screen of the game and be wow this
feels really amateurish we should you
know I'm not interested well you just
have to ask your question are you
selling to the public or are you selling
to like your friends and family cuz your
mom doesn't really care right but anyone
who doesn't know you that well yeah your
mom sure but we all know yeah the the
problem is anyone that just downloads
this game and remember they probably
downloaded several games they're
probably looking for a good game they're
probably going to give you a few seconds
to prove yourself and unless they're
really looking for this specific game
they're probably going to be a little
turned off by the presentation the
production values especially when
there's a lot of games out there that
are just as free as this one and are
just as fun as this one that have better
production values yeah you know another
another minor thing and I would love to
see you know how the holo theme and he's
turned on you know it's good you
actually guys you actually are
are you know don't have the
compatibility zoom and all that kind of
stuff on there but it's always kind of
sad when you're on a tablet these days
and you're seeing all of this you know
Gingerbread theme you know sitting on
there so true that's it I just a then
that's so easy to do just by you're not
going and actually making sure you're
targeting the most recent API levels and
just triggering the holo theme for in
this case you'd want dark but which is a
default I believe that's pretty much it
you know I mean I'm not gonna go into
kind of great detail here but no it's a
fun game I mean the yeah it really well
mechanics I don't know why there aren't
more games like this is a lot of fun
yeah alright let's go ahead and move on
Oh YouTube would like to know what you
guys thought of the music for that day
well the truth is that we played it with
sound off except for the the wait no
that makes no sense we didn't play with
sound off we played it with a hey I
don't know if the guns were clipping
really hard so I don't remember music
yeah there was music was there music I I
assume there was okay look at this I
love this like just beautiful
demonstration of exactly where me and
Dan are hmm at 12:00 p.m.
yeah exactly by 2:00 we roll it that's
right right now though we're like
yeah all right all right come on come on
come on
all right cut in the game all right so
we're gonna go next to slightly sliced
ween yeah just a little early for
Halloween it is a little early but you
know that's right it's almost October
okay Joe's has amazing production values
on here on this it is pretty good yeah
it's it's a nice game um I don't know
this is one of those games that I think
of as being kind of the adobe
illustrator game where the the graphics
it's like obviously somebody made the
graphics that has real talent you know
the got a graphic designer
but then they made like one frame yes
there's no actual animation there's just
a bunch of affine transformations yes
yeah whether you know their clothes and
this is again this is this is a
certainly if you have the choice between
having really really awesome you know a
single really awesome frame and none of
it this is the way to go absolutely
that's true but it is what
differentiates it from some of the other
physics physics games out there that
have been really really successful right
I'm like you know right now the bar is
pretty high in physics games people a
lot of choices there's been a lot of
really successful games and so you know
again great presentation but you know
the kind of the bar has to be up here
yeah and as far as upping the bar I i
well you can see what the gameplay I I
didn't feel like it had a significant
amount to offer I mean I feel this is
exactly like heaven in hell Wow really
but yeah yeah so basically the idea is
you're gonna slice through one or more
pieces of I don't know wood I guess um
and that's gonna make your your bat roll
around until he falls into the haunted
house right no we have to both get the
bat into the jana into the haunted house
and you have to collect as many pumpkins
as possible right and like I was saying
this we we saw a game last year it was
called heaven hell right or angels and
demons or
something like that one of those Dan
Brown type titles and it was exactly
this game but it had like an extra twist
because there were angels that behave
the way that bat does and then there
were demons that did something
completely different that escapes me at
the moment so nothing wrong with the
game plan it's certainly fun it just
doesn't really bring anything new and as
you can see the amount of animation is
really low so you're not really tempted
to identify with this bat or fall in
love with the bat or or think of them
the way that you would let's say is you
know well you know they a lot a lot of
times these games have has actually gone
through a whole bunch of phases of you
know monetization with characters and
part of the reason that they monetize
well with characters is people actually
connect with those characters and a lot
of people identify those characters
strangely enough even what you're doing
is fleeing those characters into a brick
wall
you're still somehow identifying those
characters and yeah absolutely
and so you know that's that's always
nice too and yeah I think that that that
is kind of what the game is missing is
animation but because the game is
otherwise quite good this is another
thing you know this dialogue is is cool
wanted I'd love to see it be a hollow
dialogue and - I'd love it I'd love to
see it
actually you know in this case be a
themed dialogue it makes sense to have
these things kind of themed around the
game so you know with all the other
present we were just heart rate ho and I
were just talking about this last hour
in the app review that there are some
apps where you can tell that they had a
great designer and then you can also
tell that they ran out of time before
they shipped and you can just map out
exactly where they ran out of time now
in this case I'm not sure if it's
running out of time we're just not
caring about it so obviously the main
screens all look great mm-hmm so why
that random dialogue popping up that
just looks ugly I don't know I can't
explain that though that was bad yes it
was you suck at this game I totally do I
totally do so fun game could be better I
think that there's there's other games
out there that are equally good and
maybe more interesting but you know it's
certainly it's also it's also
interesting to get a Halloween themed
game and then you know
that's time of year but I think it's one
of those things the and the team is
always looking for interesting stuff
around Halloween I think that it might
resonate with you know the team you
never know when in terms of when you're
looking at stuff I I wouldn't be
surprised if if if Google Play featured
this game yes true because it's there's
certainly nothing wrong with it I mean
if you're gonna ask me are you gonna
spend your hard-earned dollars on this
well no but I guess all I'm really
spending is my hard earned time still no
but I can see that some people would now
speaking of featuring it they do have a
reasonably good feature graphic in the
sense that it's legible when you make
that thing very very small you will
still be able to read the word slice
ween mhm it's a little crowded honestly
um you know got the mood you got the
haunted house got a you know those that
that haunted house stuff isn't really
going to come through those pumpkins in
the bottom are I mean why are they even
there you know this is one of those
things where he turned in terms of the
future I think that certainly going to
see the the Baker pumpkin on the bottom
you know it's okay you know I think that
I think that bats are just gonna look
like noise at the top I agree but it
looks good well and you're gonna have a
really hard time seeing that that's even
a bat because if you look at the
contrast between the black bat wings and
the in the red sky it's um it's a little
bit too low yeah yeah go if you look at
the kind of the bottom of the red sky
that you have here in the game you could
switch back to the to the tablet for a
second actually can we that's a good
question oh no I can't you can yeah so
if you're looking if you look you see
there's this very bright orange sky at
the bottom that actually be kind of a
better color to view against the back of
the bat yeah it's tough but your
graphics and the main thing is that when
when you're selling this game to people
if you first need to sell it to our
merchandising team and that's that's
very very important is if they see
something that they're like well if we
put this in the store window it's not
gonna sell yeah then they're gonna back
off and this is you know there's nothing
exactly wrong with it
but it could use a once-over by someone
who knows
to put together an ad as opposed to just
like a collage of game elements mm-hmm
okay so I think that's about it for
slice ween right now we can always
revisit it later if we don't run out of
time that's right so I think we're gonna
look at candy racer next now candy racer
is a much better example of a feature
graphic in in some ways and maybe not
quite as good in other ways the the you
know it's got one clean graphic that
makes the game look fun arguably more
fun than it actually is I the the candy
racer logo is beautiful and big it needs
to be a little bit bigger yeah it could
be a little bit bigger and you know and
it's great having the developers names
there but they're not they're not gonna
read it all but that might be okay if
they don't read it all on the phone I
mean they're you know yeah yeah that's
not a huge deal I mean it's not it's not
important information in the sense that
it would be a make or break now is you
have to read free if you do want to you
know that's that's probably the biggest
thing if you do want free to be an
important element when they're you know
when it gets featured on the phone you
know then that would definitely be
something you want to you'd want to you
know highlight a little bit more or just
get rid of and make it annoyed it'll be
very clear to users that it's free it's
okay it's kind of a it's a good question
because I you know making making it
clear to users that it's free
probably is gonna improve the chance
they actually click on it but I might
add screw although in general we do tend
to feature the paid version anyway a bit
yeah
so candy racer is nothing wrong with
this game it's a good game um like I
said the title screen is great I I can't
say enough about this you know you can
see that someone took a long time just
thinking what is fun about this game
what is what is the experience that I
want people to think they're having with
this game what and you know actually the
one thing I really love the trail that's
actually shown behind the car and I kind
of wish that was a game element
yeah I'm started going fast if you could
see like a little trail shootout behind
the car though well you kind of do I
mean there
a little particle system variance it's
not whoa
do it sorry I better I think I I may be
active stop that you have to you can't
tap when you're going uphill right a
little tip from from producer Alex who's
a pro a candy racer they technically
tell you this in will squash because you
give the beginning of the whole but I I
saw the thing that said tap to go fast
and skip right past it
mmm always a danger yeah it actually
took me three or four tries on the
second level to figure out why I
couldn't execute the loop perfectly
mm-hmm
because I was pressing down when it was
going up and then the car just flop over
yep that's exactly - does my still ran
out of time the game is you know you've
got a pretty good level of challenge to
it and and you know I think the
presentation is good I mean this is
actually an example of really doing a
lot of things right it does play audio
on the lockscreen which is a little
unfortunate and it's a dumb thing that's
definitely something to look at that's
really really easy to fix by looking at
whether or not your window is currently
active the other thing that I just want
to mention is when you're designing
games for a mobile environment you have
to remember that you'll very frequently
get played in environments that are not
at all optimal and this game in
particular suffers from that because
some of its screens have extremely low
contrast you can see this on this screen
with all of the white lettering it's
very very difficult to read if you're at
all in sunlight or if you have poor
lighting conditions at all and maybe
think about doing a little bit more
contrast on those yeah if the drop
shadow is maybe a little bit stronger
it'd be a little easier to read um
there's also a little bit of resolution
going on here too at the screen it's
just a tiny bit too low for this device
and it's noticeable another thing that
we're seeing here which is also which is
interesting is you know I don't know if
we unplug it whether we see that there
is actually letterboxing on the
right-hand side of the screen here which
is kind of unfortunate because I don't
really see any reason why there
no it's not the kind of game that needs
to be letterboxed at all yeah I was
surprised let me unplug the HDMI so we
could just we're gonna lose the feed
here I just want to see okay oh yeah
yeah yeah it's still somewhat letterbox
it's just yeah they're box yeah you
don't get more letter wrong yeah um so
you know it's what I thought so yeah
this is this is one of those things
that's really frustrating because when
you see a game like this you know that
what happens is they offered it some
random resolution that's probably you
know from a different platform known as
well this is this was this was an end
engine game some hand engine game yeah
yeah it's just it's just not well in
that case there is no excuse whatsoever
exactly the other now I want to talk
about gameplay for just a second it's
sort of revisit what you were saying
about the trail right so I'm thinking to
myself why is it that Alex Dan and I all
had exactly the same experience which is
we were like pushing on that thing to
try and get it up the hill
mm-hm and I think a lot of it is because
all of the feedback is when you tap on
this thing sparks shoot it's out its
hind end and that's that to me that says
go faster other games have dealt with
this differently like you know we looked
at the monster truck game last week and
it's controls were more centered around
tilting forward and back and maybe
having the car you know tilt forward and
back or something would would make more
sense like oh oh if I'm tilting into the
hill it's gonna be slower I don't know I
think we were all subscribing to the
mental model of pushing down and plies
pushing down on gas right and what it
actually was was pushing down exerts
some sort of force of gravity on the car
you can especially tell if the cars in
midair and he pushed down on the screen
and the cart like starts dropping even
though it's in midair so that's some
sort of gravitational constant thing
which is not especially intuitive right
and it's for interesting gameplay
mechanic once you understand it see
that's the thing I think the mechanic is
fine I think the the issue is since it
is non-intuitive
you have to give your players a little
bit more in in the way of hints or
explanations you know maybe if it's a
gravitational constant why not put a
rocket on the car that pointing into the
air and fire that thing every time you
push down I mean something that will
make it obvious that I'm getting a you
know a g-force out of this thing rather
than a rotational force on the wheels
yeah I think I think even some indicator
would be really useful to like you know
to kind of make it clear that what
you're doing is actually manipulating
gravity because that is pretty close to
the closest thing I could see well
especially when you think about other
games of this type you know for instance
one of the things that you want to do in
a lot of games is let off the gas if
you're if you find yourself catching air
off a hill in this game it's exactly the
opposite if you're catching air off a
hill you want to tap so you can fall
back down to the to the hill I catch
those stars so it is a good mechanic hmm
it is fun it's a fun game absolutely but
it's frustrating to learn and I think it
could be less frustrating if there were
a little bit more acknowledgment that
this is a non-intuitive mechanic it is
yeah that's something in there to give
you intuition about what's going on
absolutely and the game is very hard I
will definitely say that you know like
even just getting making progress to
levels is actually somewhat challenging
I would probably take a slight tone down
of the challenge to get through the
level and really focus people on getting
all of the stars
right because and getting the candies
because that that I think that's
actually one of the secrets to Angry
Birds success is it's actually
relatively easy to make it through a lot
of the levels you don't get stuck very
often but then you know then there is
that extra challenge for the more
hardcore gamer of actually going through
and trying to gold star really didn't
notice this the first time through but
the stars aren't actually points their
time so you get a second for every star
you get mmm which makes for an
interesting mechanic because you're
scored on how much time you have when
you get to the end of the love right
right which you then as the player have
to balance between how fast you shoot
through and how much care you take in
click the stars versus just catching air
and trying to you know skip a different
tire well I think what Dan's saying is
you know that's fine that it's a good
mechanic
but there's more replay people will play
a level more often to three-star it than
they will to pass it if they just get
stuck and can't pass the level then they
may stop playing the game altogether but
if it can't to restart the level hey you
know I've I've had some levels where I
go back 20 30 times until I've gotten
all the score I could possibly get yeah
there is bronze silver and gold food
well depending on how much time you have
left right right right that the bronze
level was actually I think it's anything
could be a little easier to get to the
bronze level very might that would be my
fever yeah my my advice would be you
know the bronze or wait you know there's
there's some level where it's like yay
you got to the end finally and that you
know give give people a way to get to
the next level without actually getting
to the targets that you've set for
bronze silver gold alright so let's go
to the next game which is GSN casino
absolutely so GSN casino is a slot
machine game we love slot machine games
we cannot get enough of them yeah you
know it's the truth is that that slot
machines are very very easy games to
write basic versions out of and they're
hard for games to actually bounce well
that's right they're also very very
popular they just they don't really hit
our demographic yeah our meaning in my
demographic not not where our meeting
Google plays Yeah right right no they're
going to play ya know it's just tough
because there isn't anyone that works at
Google that likes slot machine games I
don't know why I printed someone who
works here for no on the MS we're not
retired that's possible and yeah and it
is more than just a slot machine game
let's be fair there's you know there are
there's video bingo and video poker as
well but it's basically a video casino
simulation see this I don't understand
is this
under what circumstances would you play
this because you know I can see going to
Vegas and dropping a little bit on the
slot but when you're doing that you at
least get free drinks right well we are
we're getting free drinks for playing
the game right now that's true
yeah exactly that would make it much
better yeah so in any event I'm gonna
yeah so at least you've got some some
variety right yeah and that's actually
been my complaint about a lot of slots
games is it feels like a slots game will
build an engine and then just reskin it
over and over and over again
whereas in a real casino of course you
get some of that certainly there's a ton
of slot machines that are just Reece
kins of each other but the games that
are actually making money are the ones
that have some sort of hook to them
that's different from other slot games
and they do try to at least design
things differently if it's the exact
same like 21 line combo you know lines
going everywhere you know you can play
coins in different ways but the patterns
are all exactly the same like this right
you know I've seen a lot of games where
although all they will do is take
something like this and change out the
background art and call it a new game
and that's no fun at all yeah you know
for slot machines I think that what I
really want to see is someone taking it
to the next level
doing things you can't do in Vegas or
you won't the people won't do in Vegas
for various reasons and and actually
going you know kind of holding up the
casino stealing thing you're well you
know that that would be entertaining
actually I don't I wouldn't mind a whole
3d FPS you know built into the casino
game but you know but I but you know
more more than you know in terms of like
these bonuses like you can really spend
time on them because because this isn't
just a game where you're trying to steal
as much money from people as possible
yours is a game where you're actually
trying to entertain at the same time so
you can really take things to the next
level you don't have to worry well the
bonus round takes 30 seconds that's 30
seconds where the machine is in use you
can say it actually takes three minutes
to get through the bone
this round and you do a lot of things
that's interesting you're also not as
concerned about payouts you know in a
casino you know then these games are
usually paying at it like 95 percent you
know so you're you do because you want
people to continue participating playing
you know buying it occasionally but
feeling like they're getting value by
comparison because there's going to way
out at a hundred and ten percent if you
wanted to you could but then you might
have no one then you would most likely
not have anyone buying anything unless
you're monetizing ads only so so most of
the time you know these are monetizing
the same way casinos do in the sense
that you are you know ultimately buying
buying tokens here eventually I will run
out of buying tokens and running out of
them you know so but you know it's it's
a decent game I'd like to that I said
well I mean and actually this game is a
really really good example of what I'm
talking about which is you know you've
got like the cannon barrage that comes
up and all these little things that make
this feel like a different game than the
next game or the game after that you
know just it's not just a bunch of
different artwork that you pulled off of
like Shutterstock yeah I mean the one
thing I would say about this is it um
the rut the resolution is good but it's
still noticeably blurry on this tablet
especially the text you know it's and in
my general my general feeling is
actually the backgrounds here are fine
but I would when you see like Jolly
Roger and cannon barrage you can really
really see some filtering going on there
and it just makes your eyes try to focus
on it there's also kind of weird because
it's a graphic but the kerning on Roger
just kind of irks me when I look at it
it's like the R looks like it's just a
several pixels farther away than the
rest of the characters and if you're
going to go through and you're going to
get going to do the artwork for your
text it's just make it look really good
because right now it looks like
combination of blurring in a little bit
you know you're such a funky I am such a
funky it's true but yeah it is just a
darn shame to have you know a bad
resolution on a tablet like this because
let's face it tablet games are you know
games on tablets are more popular
thinking
phones and this asics transformer prime
is now the low end of tablet resolution
there's very few tablets that have a
lower resolution than this so if you
can't do a 720p set of artwork you may
just want to skip Todd tablets all
together I mean I actually you know it's
funny because it depends on the game
like this game actually looks looks much
better
and again it's making use of more it's
making use of more fonts and let and it
doesn't have text that's we rendered
outside of fonts other than I think this
gem bonus one over here and you know it
makes it makes it makes a really big
difference you know the game feels much
more like it's actually designed for
this resolution so you know whatever
whenever possible use outline font I
think that's just basically become the
that's basically become the this kind of
gold standard here so it looks like you
know again what I'm excited which I
haven't gotten to in this in a lot of
these games is actually getting to the
is getting to the bonus round you see I
have to disagree really I think the
those outline fonts over the top of
those oysters look terrible I think that
I mean they're they're legible for some
definition of legible but they just look
pasted on I mean they don't look like
they're part of the art oh no I know
that I didn't say the art design is
actually is actually good for that I
mean that that's you still have to
design around the factory of outline
fonts there right you know I think
that's I would totally agree with you in
you know in that sense but at least I'm
not like my I'm not squinting trying to
see them and my eyes are not drawn to
them trying to focus on them which is so
key you know what what I've seen done
that would actually be really effective
in a game like this is do all of your
graphics in something like SVG yeah
there's some good free FCT renders work
great on on Android you remember bouncy
Mouse did that absolutely well yeah and
it's actually the code that was used in
the side of Android affine actually
available and open source and it's it's
a really nice SVG to Android canvas
renderer essentially yeah so you can
take your illustrator files or whatever
and import them instead of rasterizing
them and importing them as bitmap
you import them as SVG's which is
usually a much smaller format and is
gonna render beautifully at almost any
resolution and especially as screens get
denser that becomes very very important
yeah I know it's it gets a great way of
keeping the game size small you have to
be careful obviously because it's very
very easy to create really really large
SVG files to you know if you use certain
effects like as you start using lots of
gradients you're like no don't you don't
put the gradients in your SVG files
actually render those separately because
it's a lot of SVG exporters will just
you know throwing tons and tons and tons
of geometry into the SVG well like
everything else there's no magic bullet
but I think this could really benefit
from being vector eyes especially since
you know it's the sort of thing you draw
it once and then you're done you know
you can you could rasterize for this
particular resolution and then cache it
if you wanted to so it's not like you're
spending a huge amount of cpu to make it
look nice now you know other things
interesting about this it actually has
the swipe mechanic there which is kind
of nice very obvious yeah I like these
screens they look good they're you know
they're big but you know as I get older
and frailer I don't mind that much yeah
I think and I think that's certainly the
target audience we're talking about here
you know it's a somewhat older audience
you know we find that younger people are
tend to play these slots less in very
very much like in the casinos it is it
is an older audience so it makes sense
to make sure everything's really real
edge Abul very very much in your face
with a touch target it's big touch
target that yeah I mean this is this is
this is a nice design also you know this
is a good we talked a lot with Android
about poor use of gradients this is a
good use of gradients these buttons look
good they don't look bubbly
they don't look I like you're overusing
the gradient effect you just got a
slight little effect on those so that
they don't leak completely flat and that
I think that's appropriate to the games
style yeah and it really does feel like
if you've been if you've been to you
know Vegas and seeing the way the
casinos market these game
you know it doesn't really feel like
there's a lot of commonality between
this and the way the casinos are
actually marketing to games
in data so you know I I say you know
this is a really nice job I see there's
no reason to be honest why they wouldn't
feature this other than there's so many
games like it and the competition is
fierce you know if you're gonna make a
slots game be prepared to really have to
spend to drive people to it because
there's just so much competition in this
area there are so many good games yeah
well and of course you're you're
competing with some really really large
social network players absolutely big
content including GSN GSN is not a small
player either so you know it's a you
know this is if you're in this space in
an i night you know by all means you
know you're sittin making slot games
make awesome slot games because it's and
and be prepared to not just make an
awesome slot game but be prepared to
spend a lot of money to drive people to
it because because it's you know this is
one of those times where you know you
know the game monetization model is
really straightforward and you know
there's a lot of people there's a lot of
people here will love to be playing
getting your blame these games are not
hard to program yes they need a lot of
art but around design there's a lot of
design things into this to make it to
make it you know so that does do all
those things and right now my hats off
to those people but it's not a technical
issue yeah well when one of these days
when I get sick of being a good person
I'm totally gonna go to Vegas and write
slot machine code I hear you can make a
ton of money that way so let's get
happen I guess prints on there and they
are good people yeah they're really good
people no no well some more the Dark
Nebula is probably the most interesting
you I'm glad we saved it for last it's a
it's a really interesting metric and now
this is one of those things honestly I'm
I'm always sad when I see this over six
million downloads on iOS and it's got
like 5,000 downloads on Android and why
is that damn
I assume that it's because it just
hasn't gotten in front of a lot of
people I mean that says you know also
ultimately well you know I'm gonna say
that's true
but also you know this is really telling
tis the first thing you see on this page
is Dark Nebula is finally available on
Android well that's also true yeah you
know when you bring out a game and you
bring generate a lot of excitement you
know on another platform and then you're
later two years later you drag the game
over to to Android one is it's you know
you've kind of reduced the ability to
get any press out of kind of the general
press and you know the game is really
big on iOS you might end up seeing get
it getting some traction that way but
usually it's actually sort of uh alright
well it's here finally great
and it's been eclipsed by a bunch of
other games right it's been eclipsed
usually your marketing dollars are gone
etc now as far as their feature graphic
though I their icon says a lot about
what the game is like and except for the
stupid rounded corners which totally
don't need to be there I like it
their feature graphic is clean and
legible but it tells me nothing I on the
name of the game I thought it was a
space exploration wait I mean you hear
Dark Nebula and you're like oh I bet
there's gonna be like some I wanted I
wanted a spaceship with a planet to
celebrate and I want it and I wanted
like exploration and yeah exactly and
that it's not thinking basically if you
took this to a design committee made up
of like art school seniors and said hey
give me a design for an ad for something
called Derrick nebula and they'd be like
what is it a game is it a vodka we're
not gonna tell you anything about it
right just Johnson Dark Nebula maybe
this is what they would come up with
yeah totally so I think you know
actually a little less blurry though to
be honest well you never know because
sometimes art students get artsy but the
point is it has nothing to do with the
actual game which is more of a
combination of pinball and labyrinth
it's a you better take that out actually
I don't know
can you play the game with that it's a
tough road I actually actually played it
sideways last time I played it so we'll
see whether I can actually play it
successfully Dan will do anything to
avoid undocking the keyboard of his Asus
Transformer Prime it's true actually I'm
not even sure why why does he feel this
way what deep-seated need does this
satisfy as a very good question I think
I think what we'll get to that in a
future episode excellent
so one thing you do have to hold it in
the correct orientation when you start
because that's when it calibrates itself
oh yeah if you don't get calibrated
you're screwed yeah so that's why really
that's how you calibrated you like that
calibration I know I think actually it's
one of those things where it's probably
better to tell you that by the way
really make sure to hold it in the right
orientation now otherwise you are going
to find that it's not going to be
calibrated this is one of those things
where a little bit of AIA might go a
long way just trying to understand
exactly what the players trying to do
because you know in general the range of
a tilt sensor for that's useful for game
play is going to be much smaller than
the actual range of the sensor so if you
start seeing that the user is going off
one side or the other what a really good
game will do is to sort of adjust it so
that they can just kind of in like you
kind of calibrate as you're going I
think me that's funny I never actually
tried playing this game with the HDMI in
and I think it's not real happy about
the kind of jerky resizing that happens
when you when you actually are have the
HD actually play then you're
accidentally taking it out do you want
to put it on my Nexus 7 and and but the
yeah we might get on camera let's let's
try this one more time to see if I can
actually get through so one thing that's
really great about this game is actually
the the accelerometer controls are
really precise they do what you want it
to do like honestly it it actually feels
really really good and that's I think
the most important thing in this kind of
a game is if you're going to use
accelerometer controls and you know I am
not always a fan of accelerometer
controls
be the first one to say that it is
actually messed up quite a lot of really
good games but but in this game you know
the game is it's entirely designed
around it which is why it works yeah if
you're using the new API is that we
shipped in what was it ICS then you can
get really really incredibly good
accelerometer if you don't use the new
api's or if you're on an older device
then the accelerometer is a little bit
flaky and one things I love about the
game playing this is that you actually
have to as you see go and in order to
open doors you actually have to go over
certain areas and it gives you're you
know a character of this kind of red or
green a forcefield so I've got this red
force field another red force field
allows me to get through that wall etc
and so forth so there's a lot of really
good elements here in the gameplay that
you know I I really enjoyed yeah it is
cool I mean it can you fall off the edge
there by the way okay yeah so it's kind
of got that that marble madness thing
going on yeah no no it's a really nice
design for an accelerometer based game
you know I love to see people who are
you're doing an accelerometer based game
actually going and saying no we're gonna
design around this input method and
really try to do something cool that's
always you know that's always better
than to kind of throw it into an
existing game design and and so you know
I you know thumbs up to the designers oh
yeah look at that I just died I filled
this down I'm about to die but you're
right it is a fun game there's a few a
few of the sprites seem a little low res
but that could just be the angle and
holding no no it's definitely it's
definitely some some some some minor
resolution issues it's you know it looks
like it's one resolution step below we
have drone yeah and that's 2 7 or
transformer prime we have a youtube
question
you have been dedicated to reading
YouTube questions like a good producer
right Alex there haven't been any
comments in the past several minutes
really but yeah I think our our time
switch has injured our viewership more
people are disquiet today it's possible
that the last actual question was about
the music from their agent shooter game
yeah Wow yeah like the only poem I have
with the UI for this game for the
tilting thing I think in general
mechanic works really well the only
problem I have with it is you get to a
point where in order to go forward
you're tilting the screen away from you
and that makes actually seeing what
you're doing difficult what you're doing
is like if it's like this you're not
going like this and you almost have to
sort of lean over and yeah I noticed
that and despite what Dan was saying
about calibration if I hold it like this
while the levels starting it still wants
to lie flat well I'm playing it that's
not cool guys only not cool if there was
just a way to or to have it calibrate
for holding it in front of you like a 45
degree angle or something like that so
you tilt a little bit you can still see
perfectly what's going on or if I had a
specially built table with like Leonardo
da Vinci pulleys and stuff coming out
that I guess so yeah I want to say yeah
exactly Baron peripheral for this guy
exactly right but as it stands yeah
control is good but could be a lot
better if you would just let it so
here's how you actually do it that's a
game there's actually calibrate if you
can calibrate right in here oh you can
actually calibrate them during the games
this is my I hadn't noticed because it's
kind of hidden in it but if you actually
you can actually recalibrate game by
pressing the screen with two fingers so
there we are oh it's calibrated here
let's see how much more playable it is
so you know again it may just be a
question of just being able to find this
because obviously needed none of us
found it well that's interesting because
it does work a lot better but is also a
lot more jerky for some reason really
yeah
understand that hmm
yeah well okay it does help them it's
good that it's possible to recalibrate
but I would seriously consider just
switching your default over to someone
holding it in front of you either
vertically or 45 degrees yeah well it is
tricky like you don't like honestly
because of the design of the game of you
you calibrate it too far up it also
becomes really hard to play well so
since it's obviously very quick to
calibrate it what I don't understand is
why why wouldn't I just calibrate it
every time I every time I start
alright so forgive it you know give it a
little countdown you know you got three
seconds and then you're gonna go and the
average player is gonna put it into the
position where they don't want it to
move and the last thing you want to do
is have your ball start to move when you
start it so I don't know maybe that's
just me
but yeah this this accelerometer is not
nearly as you know my goodness it's no
it's it's almost unplayable when I
calibrate it to a 45 degree angle yeah
it is it really but I don't understand
why I'm not sure either yeah that would
be really interesting to find out so any
case you know we really like Dark Nebula
I think it's you know it's a game that
that you know that we all enjoyed
playing and you know I think it's a
little hard to play when you have it
plugged in HD mine trying desperately to
keep the HDMI from from getting pulled
out but right so if you have that
problem you might want to steer clear
this one but other than that but you
know it's certainly a really thoroughly
well-constructed game and I you know I
honestly it is I'm looking forward to
going through and getting higher and
higher in level in the game it is a
really fun game and love it well you
know I and this is this I bought this
game so I know personally so nice isn't
that because we made you it's true but I
did so nice all right
well alright Red Hook ESB 5 great games
we are out of here so thanks a lot for
watching the Friday review remember that
next week we will once again have an
open topic mm-hmm so go ahead and
nominate whatever you want just please
please please put a link to it I'm
talking to you Dark Nebula guy and give
us your your info so if we get around to
it and we're not too drunk and we're you
know feeling good that day we'll try and
invite you onto a G+ hangout at some
point yeah it's great it's great to have
developers when they come online we
could talk to them about the games and
kind of get an idea of you know why
certain design decisions were made so
it's always great if you're available at
this time which is now 12 noon PST to
actually go and join us live on the show
so we're gonna go ahead and keep it at
noon PST for a week if it looks like
nobody watches at that time we might
switch it's cool let us know our only
ask is that it needs to be some point
within shouting distance of working
hours for us and preferably within
drinking hours so my nothing before 9:00
a.m.
yeah night 9:00 in the morning is kind
of the cutoff I refuse to drink before
9:00 so right because 9:00 we've only
just stopped drinking you don't to start
again so so I have a great weekend
everyone and definitely continue to vote
on the moderator page and nominate your
games and your favorite games and let's
let's see some great stuff for next week
actually was it was a really fun week I
thought there's a lot of yeah there's
some good stuff I really like I think
our quality of submissions has really
gone up so we appreciate it thanks for
watching happy Android play us out